20-18 was a big year for VR with titles
like beat saber but if these games are
any indication 2019 is shaping up to be
a sight to behold for virtual reality
gaming here are three upcoming VR games
coming to oculus rift for you to keep
your eye on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
defector many VR games these days focus
on a gameplay experience more so than
taking advantage of the technology to
deliver an interactive story defector is
a sci-fi and espionage inspired thriller
that plans to take on this challenge as
you live your best life as a secret
agent taking down an evil government
agency filled with shootouts fisticuffs
and action set-pieces defector is a game
we're definitely planting a tracking
device on I mean where else are you
going to be able to drive a car into a
plane at 35,000 feet
storm land if you're itching to shoot
more robots after 2017 s robo recall
consider paying a visit to storm land
you play as a robot exploring an exotic
open world who must crack advanced
weaponry and scavenge for new parts to
upgrade your suits frame store oh man is
giving us some serious Wally vibes but
at least this time we'll be able to
bring some friends along with us
loan echo - space may be the final
frontier but for eagle-eyed gamers with
their eyes on the release calendar like
you it can be right at your fingertips
in 2019 low and echo - is a sequel to
the 2017 VR hit in which you soared
through space repairing your space
station and defended your captain from a
mysterious bio anomaly low tech Oates
who continues the story as you step back
into the role of Jack the Android as the
mystery deepens with a strong narrative
focus in addition to utilizing the VR
controls like never before
be prepared for an immersive experience
that just isn't the same with a
controller I don't know if I can do this
check those are just a few of the games
we're looking forward to coming to
oculus rift in 2019 what VR games are
you looking forward to let us know in
the comments below and for more on the
biggest games of 2019 and beyond
stick with us here at GameSpot
[Music]
you